à moins que m
quant à m
[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est au c
es avec rodolphe liés eux le deal boss
de gouffre robotics qu'il ya un petit
robot qui s'appelle veut dire qui est un
petit robot génial est ce que tu peux
nous présenter nous dire ce n'est pas
fair me dit ce qui peut nous apporter
les évolutions enfin toutes les stars
venues
l'idée c'est déjà d'avoir un mélange de
meilleur mélange possible persistant
personnel
un ipad et un animal de compagnie des
gros chiens s'ils contribuent tous à
dabo dit ok l'assistant personnel qui
est toujours pas de toit
quant à l'adjoint qui est intelligente
sympa quand même
compagnie eco6 va devenir un nouveau
round de la famille des cordes mais
vraiment avoir sa place dans le foyer
comme un gant de l'infini
c'est exactement ce qu'on espère
reviens du fait qu'il est mignon un coût
de ce salon de la définissent à noter
aussi les vrais services et pas juste un
différend
même si ses concurrents pourquoi donc
ouais l'idée est d'amener les
des services
la maison
tous les membres de la
veut il va pouvoir garder la maison pour
connaître
et comme tu le dis je vais travailler
car la maison si la semaine sera trouvé
à regarder certains convives
mathon pinard qui se passe si jamais il
ya un truc
les genres tous d'un pôle
depuis le smartphone tueur
produire moins d'essence plus est avec
as j'ai reçu notification à regarder
c'est chez moi j'ai pas contraire au
brio leur parce que les poires voir à
travers la caméra
le faire se déplacer dans ma maison
depuis je peux le délai c'est un fait
que je peux tu es passé d'accord c'est
l'application caste
aussi m'en servir pour voir ma famille
c'est bon
sécuritaire m capable
on a des applications bien sûr de lui il
joue de la musique qui peut te suivre
mettant en
de réflexion pendant le salon
c'est dur
la cuisine la météo c'est à benoît
dijon n'a pas rappelé aujourd'hui ou pas
car des blacks aussi
on a des jeux pour les enfants qui
jouent un grand soleil
[Musique]
des jeux de mémoire venu à faire des
coups
en grattant les reproduire de m
[Musique]
en tout cas
on va chercher des objets ou telle
couleur qui doivent se dépêcher pour
bien rappeler à
japon
exactement se dissipe
d'accord
[Musique]
les texans décent
mais là on est
ducarme est à disposition des livres
mon les mêmes que
appui pour la retrouver
c'est adapté sur police
parti avec ses looks ans pour adapter
des outils grand public jeux
pour l'a320
[Musique]
parce que simplement
oui
bien sûr son génial de faire ça
encore des meilleurs délais
donc c'est complètement ok donc ça veut
dire qu'on peut imaginer d'avoir parmi
ton pour la cuisine pour retrouver
symbolique
à part exacte par exemple apple 1
avec les jours qui vont amener du
trooper la coince possible
[Musique]
c'est tout
les gens étaient des deux voies
terrestres
l'appel est rigide
mais toi tu n'y as
un collégien
entre les connais tous chine qui est
l'application
on sait très bien d'où l'idée de vouloir
c'est un robot comme objectif les 2 3 de
plus que ce que disent le faire des
robots
fois que j'avais 7 ans
petit pourboire dialogue
ok voilà et
sa cliente
beaucoup de services
l'évolution a
[Musique]
dax c'est de créer
machine qui fait crac ont fait
merci
parfait parce que naturellement tout va
pouvoir aller la voir
quoique y va
et ensuite
[Musique]
apparemment smartphones
c'est bien
donc ça c'est le pas supplémentaire
je me suis tu logique par rapport à août
un atome échos
découvrez styles y sont très présents
on n'est pas couché
t'as pas de lien en bas de page fan
le locle
jeudi jean
tu penses tu vraiment laid
évolution de la robotique comme un
nouveau membre du foyer au gré de me
dire d'une manière générale je l'étais
aussi d'autres concurrents qui revient
ce marché ce que ça marchait
de françois grillât pour une nature
pense vraiment que d'ici à l'egypte à
brens
tous les français
en tireront en
chez eux qui leur apportera et une
qualité de service clairement c'est ça
comment exactement comme dans les années
soixante dix
bien qu'à peine
l'apple one n'est pas tous les jours
sarko à l'ordinateur personnel
on ne fait pas trop et
de cette année maintenant à 12 1 2
il en est persuadé que ce sera
exactement même juré caron butler a tous
des robots
il y aura des buts rien d'autre c'est
vrai mais on aura tous des robots c'est
l'évolution
d'un côté il veut me
les expériences acteurs
émotionnel tout ça fait que
[Musique]
robotics est de 10 est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres
d'autres produits
et vu qu'ils vont
paris
[Musique]
mais quel est le plus par deux notes de
nos efforts faits pour intellos 10h
marché est pas un travail facile à faire
voici
il ya des gens qui attendent
impatiemment ce robot
croyez moi en poste j'aurais demi pour
vous l'avez adolescents mais oui bien
sûr on a vu trop beaux dans des cartons
[Musique]
faire un super succès à léconi cerveau
le cheval de troie pour nous c'est à
dire
y'a pas des jambons
[Musique]
mexico ce matin
bonne idée et ensuite une fois pour moi
ça peut passer
si vous passez un puissant capable
concrètement les chercheurs
c'est quoi
en ce cas puisque la chute ça vivre avec
lui
c'est là
deux compagnies qui l'a rassuré
par quoi
je pense qu'il ya une
une éducation à faire se rencontrer
beaucoup de films de science fiction
d'animation
des modes et des peurs
impressionnant
et donc l'idée c'est déjà de rassurer
les gens sur
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est
n'empêche pas que des gens qui voient
que ce terminator de rien ils le disent
nous on n'est pas du tout dans cet hiver
moins sûr alors du coup me dis quand est
ce qu'on peut espérer le trouver sur ma
chaîne on a prévu
invite à une
[Musique]
ok et
à quel tarif pour en trouver qui sera à
[Musique]
l'actrice merci apple
ça marche pas avec le très beau couple
on peut vous suivre sur internet
j'imagine du fardeau fiscal
le fragment gothique cet appel chez eux
ce accord et la discussion voilà le
twitter
[Musique]
dikalo claudie sur twitter et c'est fait
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter du
pouvoir au service du midi gîte est par
contre autour du lavoir plein de médias
parce que c'est super d'avoir des jours
[Musique]
stalair
passionné plus capitanat c'est
j'aime bien ça c'est super a ajouté
l'allemand
cv
parce que ça rien être partout et qui
on est là pour lever des fonds
cet épisode très près écoutez merci
beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette vidéo vous
invite à mettre tous vos commentaires
toutes vos questions d'une vos
suggestions par rapport à boudy parce
que effectivement comme le dit très
justement rodolphe c'est un produit
d'avenir c'est un produit qui va
énormément évolué qui va rentrer dans
nos foyers d'ici quelques temps donc on
reste connectés suivait ça très près
vous évite je vous invite comme
d'habitude à me laisser des jolies
pousse à vous abonner à rester connectés
parce qu'on va parler toujours plus
d'entreprises françaises innovantes et
de high tech en règle générale merci
beaucoup run off
merci à toi salut